[Musica]
immaginate che le vostre giornate
termine no al tramonto non potete uscire
a fare una passeggiata
non potete socializzare non potete fare
nulla perché perché non c'è luce
la prima si trova a centinaia di
chilometri di distanza
questa è la realtà che oggi vivono
840 milioni di persone nel mondo di cui
600 milioni nell'africa sub sahariana
e infatti mi trovavo lì ero in un
villaggio nel deserto della mauritania e
lavoravo per una società che si occupava
di garantire l'accesso all'energia
erano le 8 di sera e qualche minuto dopo
tutto si spense tutto tacque tutto si
fermò
ci fu un silenzio
abissale
poi qualche giorno dopo connettendo
l'illuminazione stradale alla nostra
centrale e stavo assistendo ad una vera
rivoluzione
stavo lavorando per regalare una parte
di vita ad un gruppo di persone e quindi
avevo davanti ai miei occhi l'impatto
del lavoro che avevo scelto
l'idea del lavoro ci accompagna fin da
bambini infatti quando avevo 6 anni mi
chiedevano che il lavoro vuoi fare da
grande non dicevo voglio fare
l'ingegnere l'astronauta dicevo voglio
avere una fattoria sì perché è stare a
contatto con la natura con gli animali
veder trasformare dei semi in frutta e
verdura mi sembrava la cosa più naturale
al momento
poi crescendo questa idea si trasformò
quando all'età di 12 anni con mio padre
un folle tuttofare decidemmo di
costruire un pannello solare termico per
la nostra casa
inutile dirvi che nessuno di noi aveva
competenze tecniche ma decidemmo di
provarci così dopo l'estate avevamo un
pannello solare termico funzionante per
la nostra casa è la cosa più
sorprendente fu che funzionava senza
essere connessa una presa di corrente e
nonostante l'avessi studiato e sapessi
che questo fosse proprio il suo scopo
vederle in funzione mi sembra
incredibile
una magia
quindi si faceva sempre più chiaro nella
mia testa un concetto volevo lavorare
con l'energia che veniva dalla natura
l'idea era ancora un po confusa ma col
tempo si conferma poi crescendo
l'adolescenza e liceo l'università tutte
le scelte che prendevo erano volte verso
il trovare la mia strada così decisi di
iscrivermi ad economia e scegliendo
quelle materie di carattere energetico e
sostenibile scoprì che dietro quell
energia che viene dalla natura che tutti
oggi sappiamo come si chiama l'energia
rinnovabile
c'è un mondo da scoprire e da imparare
così studio mi informo e decido di
lavorare in questo settore
durante la ricerca di un tirocinio
incontro un imprenditore il quale aveva
una società che si occupava di accesso
all'energia
durante uno dei nostri colloqui
chiacchierate dice sì ma di cosa si
occupa esattamente questa società qual è
il fine ultimo di questa società
ecco questo fu un momento che mi aiutò a
metabolizzare un concetto che ancora
oggi porto dentro di me
questo concetto è il valore e
l'importanza del nostro impatto come
lavoratori
infatti durante
questa chiacchierata mi parlò di cosa
significa garantire l'accesso
all'energia mi parlò di sicurezza mi
parlò di prospettive
mi parlò di vite salvate
così mi innamorai dell'idea mi innamorai
di questo progetto e mi innamorai
dell'impatto che poteva avere questo
lavoro e inizia a lavorare per questa
società e ci aveva sedi in italia in
inghilterra e in africa in pochissimo
tempo fu catapultato a londra nella
famosa siti tutti i giorni per
raggiungere il mio ufficio attraversavo
il london bridge insieme a migliaia di
giovani da tutto il mondo
quel ponte in quel momento mi sembrava
semplicemente un mezzo un mezzo per
raggiungere il mio ufficio col passare
dei mesi e degli anni invece mi resi
conto che quel ponte rappresentava il
raggiungimento di un sogno
rappresentava il lavorare per le
migliori società al mondo che a loro
volta avevano un impatto
allora mi chiesi qual è l'impatto che
avevano quelle migliaia di giovani che
ogni giorno attraversavano il london
bridge con me ma soprattutto qual era
l'impatto che volevo avere qual'era
l'impatto che ricercava in un'azienda
passai da una ricerca ad una potenziale
risposta che si concettualizza a
conclusione del mio primo viaggio in
africa
e in africa a ninja la routine era
sempre la stessa sveglia presto ognuno
svolgeva le proprie mansioni
e poi ci si riuniva c'era
ecco a cena si sentivano soltanto le
nostre voci
nessun rumore nessun brusio il silenzio
poi un giorno con le temo
l'illuminazione stradale alla nostra
centrale
ecco proprio quel giorno
qualche minuto dopo le 8 tutti
aspettavano soltanto il buio quel
silenzio che accompagnava tutte le
nostre giornate
e invece successe qualcosa di
straordinario il villaggio si illuminò è
così d'improvviso donne bambini uomini
uomini e giovani uscirono dalle loro
abitazioni e davvero l'opportunità di
socializzare è però l'opportunità di
vivere una nuova parte della loro
giornata
è così
in quel in quel secondo
ricordo
l'espressione del viso dei più giovani i
quali si riunirono di fronte la nostra
centrale
poiché godeva del faro del faro più
luminoso e quel punto quell'esatto punto
ancor oggi è diventata la loro piazza è
diventato il loro luogo di incontro
così tutte le ore passate davanti a una
scrivania tutto l'impegno la dedizione e
la fatica vennero condensati in un
esatto istante
tutti noi avevamo davanti ai nostri
occhi l'impatto del lavoro che avevamo
scelto
quindi capi che è garantire l'accesso
all'energia non significa semplicemente
dare l'opportunità di connettere un
elettrodomestico ad una presa ma invece
significa molto di più significa acqua
potabile significa riduzione di malattie
significa riduzione dello spreco di cibo
e ancora garantire una connessione che
quindi porta l'accesso a un educazione e
alla comunicazione
potrei tradurre tutti questi impatti in
un'unica parola
opportunità
stavo lavorando per regalare un
opportunità ad un gruppo di persone
quelli che ho deciso di raccontarvi
stasera sono gli elementi gli episodi
più significativi della mia vita fin ora
ovviamente che sono tutti collegati da
una delle costanti che determina nostra
vita il lavoro si perché diciamocelo il
lavoro determina scelte
il lavoro è anche gioia il lavoro e
fatica il lavoro è speranza ma il lavoro
è anche impatto
ognuno di noi ha un impatto ea un lavoro
che produce un impatto anche il tuo
lavoro hanno impatto anche il suo lavoro
in impatto tutti hanno un impatto e come
comunità abbiamo un enorme potenziale
quello di decidere di investire in un
sistema che punti ad avere un impatto
orientato però ad un futuro possibile
perché possiamo inquinare come
compensare possiamo aiutare come invece
sfruttare un gruppo un gruppo sociale
possiamo ancora deforestare come
preservare
quindi chiedo a ognuno di voi di
riflettere su qual è l'impatto del
vostro lavoro
cosa aiutate produrre come fate
tutti i giorni e cosa aiutate a produrre
tutti i giorni della vostra vita perché
esiste un opportunità abbiamo tutti
un'opportunità quella di risvegliare le
nostre coscienze di formarci di studiare
e di portare all'interno delle aziende
per cui lavoriamo
una vera rivoluzione la rivoluzione del
nostro impatto
[Applauso]